i got to ask you a question
i use paws a lot
do you know what that means yeah
is that homophobic no okay not to me
okay i gotta ask because my guy's like
yo man uh yo i need extra meat on my
sandwich i'm gonna pause
i just want to make sure pause it's not
it's not um just one thing about gays
gays are sometimes we are actually extra
sensitive right um because you know
just how we looked at a lot of stuff you
know gays are kind of you know thrown to
the wayside i consider you know bottom
of the barrel um
of things or you know even when we're
dealing with you know men we consider
like you know soft or you know different
things like that so gays is always on a
defense
but that's not uh that's not to me
that's not that's not offensive that's
not offensive oh no got to make sure man
you calling me something crazy outside
my name is offensive
but the pause is pauses yeah that's cool
it's cool okay but you guys gotta make
sure you gotta get cause i'll be pausing
a lot now i mean
i'll say that like
i'm like yo that's me and my brother
trey me and my brother uh trey tracks my
producer like if i would have been like
i want an extra minute he would have
been like hey yo like oh
pause like hey what
oh i could be like with my [ __ ] son and
my [ __ ] like put his arm around my
shoulder my brother's gonna be like hey
yo like that's our pause
so nice